(hip hop music)
- Let's start with this.
I fully, fully,
100,000% with no hedge
do not believe that you
can teach entrepreneurship.
Right, so that's awkward,
you know.
(audience laughter)
What I mean by that is
that it's crazy for me
that that word is now
considered like cool and good.
Like when I was your age,
20 years ago, entrepreneur
meant that you
were a fucking loser
that was figuring it out, right?
So watching what's happening
to the world right now
where this has become a hot
topic is interesting to me
and like I'm super pumped
that people now value that
in a different way
than they did.
I grew up a
D and F student, right?
And the reason I grew
up a D and F student
was I was unable to sit in
a room like this and listen
to whoever was sitting up here
because all I wanted to do
was sell shit, right?
And so, that's all
I've ever known.
I've had no other gear.
Somewhere around
fourth grade when I got
an F on a science test
I literally, like that day,
was like yeah, that makes
sense to me because I don't
give a fuck about Saturn, right?
(audience laughter)
Like I don't,
that's not who I am.
And so I think if there
was anything I could do,
if there was anything I could
do that would be awesome
for you guys to make the
most money I could make
I would create a test or
a drug that allowed people
to become self aware.
I think that the number one
thing that I could tell you,
'cause I'm desperate to
bring value since I'm here,
is I think everybody
lies to themselves.
And I think all of
you want certain things
to be happening with you.
You want yourself
to be something.
And I think what you
need to do more of,
and if I can give you, clearly
I'm coming out the gate
with my best piece of advice,
I really do think you have to
audit who you actually are.
I think that
America as a society
has done a really good job
in selling us how
to fix the things
that we naturally aren't.
There's a lot of money
being made on us forming
into something we can't be.
And I either through
massive ego and bravado,
complete ignorance,
I don't know what it
was early on in my life.
Maybe the outrageous level
of self-esteem that my mom
instilled in me.
I was able to quickly,
very, very early on.
And let me take it back,
because a lot of you
don't know who...
I was born in Belarus in
the former Soviet Union.
And so I came here when I was
three and we were super poor.
I lived in a studio apartment.
I know what it tastes like
to walk five miles to K-Mart,
buy toilet paper, come home
and then sit there for an hour
and split the toilet
paper to get efficiency.
And that's a huge
advantage for me, right?
Like the fact that I've
been working 19 hours a day
everyday for the last 20 years
is easy for me, it's the
only gear I knew, right?
I was poor,
I sucked shit at school.
It was the only
gear I had, right?
So like I sit here with
enormous disrespect
and with enormous
assumptions around all of you
that you're just too
soft to beat me, right?
That I think that
you've had it better.
And that that alone doesn't
allow you to beat me.
And that's how I think of
entrepreneurship
in a very rugged, very
raw, much dirtier way.
I've been investing
for about seven years.
The first three
things I invested in.
In 2007 after
I got my wine business,
and I realized that this
internet thing was gonna be big,
was Facebook,
Twitter and Tumblr, right?
And then I've collectively
gotten stupider
since that moment, mainly
because I didn't think of myself
as an investor when
I invested in those companies.
I just thought that
Ev Williams, Zucks,
and David Karp were
really fucking smart
and we're gonna win, right?
And so when I think about
Uber, like Travis is one of my
best, best buddies, like
now he has a lot of press,
I'm sure a lot of
you know who he is.
That just makes a lot of sense
because all the negative
press he gets makes sense
because he's a fighter.
But he was the only
CEO of that company
because Uber's had a fight
city hall for the
last four years.
It's hard to fight the Mafia
that owns the taxi
service in Vegas.
That takes, I can't do that,
I'm too not
confrontational, right?
So I think that the number
one thing that you can do.
You know,
I'm desperately competitive
and wanna be the person
that brings the most value
to you out of all these talks.
Like I secretly sit here
and say, "Oh they're gonna
"get all these people
that they've heard of,
"but I'm gonna be the one
that tells them something
"that actually fucking matters."
And that one thing is you
need to bet on your strengths
and don't give a fuck
about what you suck at.
Way too many people in
this room a gonna spend
the next 30, 40 years
of their lives trying
to check the boxes of the
things they're not as good at.
And that you're going to waste
a fuckload of time and lose.
I highly recommend auditing
yourself or if you have
no fucking empathy or
EQ or self-awareness,
find someone in your family
or friendship that does,
and let them tell
you who you are.
And once you believe
that, either for yourself
or someone else told you,
go directly, all chips
all into that, because that
is the only possible way,
in my opinion watching
from the outside, that is,
let me rephrase,
that is a very highly
likely way of over indexing.
Because the truth is, if
you wanna be an anomaly
you've gotta act like one.
You know, like...
and so that's it.
That's what I got.
So thanks for having me.
(audience laughter)
- I think that,
I think that,
I think it's been
really interesting
for me for the
last three years to watch.
So tech, when I was
investing in it for me
and when I was growing
my business in the '90s
and then when I really got into
it in '04, five, six, seven,
you know people were in it
'cause they were really good
at it or in it
or really passionate.
Right now, everybody
thinks that if you're 22
and you have an idea you're
entitled to a startup, right?
And so, the thing that's
been really fascinating
for me to watch,
the dichotomy of structure
and understanding
how to play the game
versus entrepreneurship.
So for example,
again, being a dick about it,
I know I'm sitting in a room
full of number twos,
threes, and fours, right?
There's so many
people in this room
that are like gonna be dot,
like could be dominant,
number twos, threes, and fours.
And I'm pissed that
the narrative now
is that you need
to be a number one
and have your company.
Because a lot of
people are gonna lose
or leave money on the table
because that's just the
narrative, right?
And so, the difference for me
between a two, three,
and four, and a one
is having a stomach.
And so one of the things
that we've seen a lot of
because Zucks went
to Harvard and like
literally being east coast bound
like watching all these kids
that are going to
Ivy League schools,
including Stanford so
mixing the whole like mix.
Just like actually
everybody's a better student
than I was,
so I'll just call it everybody.
But, watching the
elite top three percent
so many of those players,
guys and gals,
have come into to game in
the last 24 or 36 months
and have lived a narrative
where things have been good.
Right?
Like, you know again,
I'm using a lot of prejudice.
I default into thinking
that like you guys
were way more capable than me
than figuring out how
to map yourselves
to go through the school system.
Like you understood that game.
Like very honestly,
like it's cool to be like
oh fuck school and I sucked,
and then I was a
great entrepreneur.
But like, it would have been
cool to have figured it out.
Like I would have been fine
getting C's and B's, right?
Like that would have
been interesting
then I would have
had a better life.
Like college would
have been more fun.
I wouldn't have went
to Mount Ida College
where seven of
my eight core friends
fucking went to jail.
Right, so, you know
(chucking) if you
wanna keep it real.
So, you know,
but I just couldn't
and I think that that's what
I'm seeing the reverse
of right now which is
on the flip side being
an entrepreneur
and really running
a successful company,
here's the problem.
There isn't just
like one teacher
who fucking decides
and you figured out how
to map him or the syllabus
or whatever the fuck you guys do
to figure out what you needed.
The problem is when you
have a startup or a business
you're playing to the market.
And the market doesn't give
a fuck who your parents were
or how you rolled,
or what happened before.
The market just cares
about the market.
And so I think that what's
been really interesting
for me to observe,
and I would say is something
for you guys to think about is
again you're gonna wanna
think in a certain way
versus what may be the reality.
Or you might
underestimate yourself,
it just depends on your DNA.
But, the ability to adjust
is the entire game.
Like, I'm so proud that
I change my mind everyday.
My dad used to get so pissed
when I was building
Wine Library.
He would always be like
fuck, he's like,
he would say like,
"Three months ago you said Ricky
"was gonna be
the best employee."
I'm like I changed my mind.
He's shit, fire him.
Or, he's like, "You said
sparkling wine was important
"and now you just eliminated
it from the key spot."
I'm like I changed my mind.
Like my ability to only be
comfortable in massive chaos
has been my biggest
asset as an entrepreneur.
Like I would never
take a fucking note.
Like that scares
the piss out of me
what these three people
are doing right now, right?
(audience laughing)
And so, now (chuckles)
that may work for
them and I'm not
like back to the
opening statement.
Like you need to do you
plenty people that make
a fuck load more money than me
and have won bigger
take fucking notes.
The key, the key though,
the key is way too
many people are doing,
like here's a good one.
You know what really
pissed me the fuck off?
(audience laughing)
(sighing)
I'm completely driven
by like happiness
and like I'm crippled
by like chaos.
Like you know VaynerMedia,
which is now 500 people.
Update your shit.
(audience laughing)
VaynerMedia is
completely dictated by,
like I'm a dictator of HR.
All I care about
is the atmosphere,
all I care about
is how people, intern,
is how people roll.
I think I've fired the four
most talented, smartest people
that have worked for me
because if you don't know how
to play with the other
boys and girls, you're out.
Because I suffocate under, you
know, conflict and negativity
and nobody's better than
me, so you gotta go.
So what really pissed
me off in tech world was
when Steve Jobs' book came
out, when he was dying,
when it was all about Steve
three or four years ago,
I literally watched a lot
of my tech start-up friends
start being like
a dick to their staff.
Because Jobs was tough,
everybody fell into the romance
of I have this big vision
and I'm gonna be
a dick like Steve, right?
And I thought that was
really interesting for me
to watch that half decade
of literally watching
people I know and then
watching them act differently
because the status or
the icon of the moment,
and you see a lot of that.
And so that is probably the
energy I'm trying to bring
to this class today, which is
you can look at how people roll
and it's great to admire
and things of that nature
but it's so damn important
to stick to your DNA, right?
And what you're good at.
And to recognize that you
need to surround yourself,
whether it's your co-founder,
or whether it's the
people that work for you,
like all I do is hire the
people that are the opposite
of me, that bring the other
value, that bring me the ability
to remember what the fuck
that meeting was about
and go make sure it happens.
You know,
whatever it may be, right?
And so I think
that's another thing
that I would highly recognize.
I think the other thing
you guys should recognize
is how ridiculously lucky
you are, but how interesting
the supply and demand of
your luck is changing.
Meaning, it's never been
better to be an entrepreneur.
Right now, right this
second, is the greatest.
There's massive destruction,
I promise you because I spend
a fuckload of time with
everybody in corporate America,
the big companies are so
fucking slow and stupid,
it's almost unbearable, right?
So that's great for us,
if we don't have money
and we've got time, right?
And so that's great.
And the cost of entry's easy.
There's so many people that
are envious of the lucky things
that happen to me investing in
Uber and Birchbox and Twitter
and all those things,
that now everybody
in their thirties to sixties
that has any level of money
is chasing any kid in
a hoodie with an idea
and giving them money to
invest in their start-up
because everybody's
looking for their exit, right?
So on top of the fact that the
internet is hitting maturity
and every user's on a
smartphone and blah blah blah
and we're at scale, on
top of that, in parallel,
there's a fuckload of dumb
money chasing it and looking
to give it to anybody they can.
Which is your opportunity.
So we need to take
advantage of that horse shit
and actually,
if you think you're ready,
you should literally start
your company right now
because I'm sure it's
important to finish this class
and whatever, but tomorrow
the market could collapse
and you'll miss
this opportunity.
Literally right now on a
fucking half-ass idea, right?
With like two or three
connections from your parents
or professors or emailing
me and I introduce you
to somebody, you can literally
raise a million dollars
on your horse shit idea.
(Audience laughter)
But we need to like, I want
everybody to understand
that all it takes
is something crazy,
like a terrorist attack, or
some fucking bank full of shit
breaking, all it, like
tomorrow that can go away.
I think it's super important
for everybody to understand
that if you're itching, I think
you should start tomorrow,
because the money's there, and
you're gonna need the money.
Because, this
happens all the time.
Everybody that looked
like you in 2008 and 2009,
they went and got jobs.
Everybody that looked
like you in 2002 and 2003,
after the first bubble,
they went and got jobs.
So if you're
a true entrepreneur,
if you're sitting here like,
no I'm an entrepreneur,
I'm not just in the class,
you need to seriously
concentrate on where we
are at this exact moment
in the market and recognize
how fruitful it is for you,
how much of
an advantage you have.
You may want
to seriously consider
and take
advantage of it.
Because it could really
go away in a second,
and then you've gotta wait,
like if it collapsed tomorrow,
if there's a bubble burst,
you're gonna have to wait
three to five years
to get your shot.
When bubbles burst, no fucking
kid with an idea gets dick.
Got it?
(Audience laughter)
That's a good one.
I like that one.
But that's what happens.
So I think that's important.
Timing's massively important.
And so that's why
I'm pushing that agenda.
(Audience member sneezes)
Bless you.
I think the other
thing to think about is
I think that, here's
just some random shit
and then maybe
we can go into Q&amp;A.
I think that Uber, Airbnb,
and Instacart are not anomalies
the way a lot of
people in my world think.
I think they're just a preview.
I think if everybody here
understands that the number one
asset to everybody in the
world is time, and if you can
figure out how to buy and sell
it back, that's a big coup.
So I think the biggest
reason I got excited
about Uber years
ago was I realized,
holy shit, this isn't
about transportation,
this is about a company
that sells me back time.
As a matter of fact, I actually
boycotted LA for four years.
I actually didn't come
to LA for four years
'cause I hated fucking
coming here so much
because I didn't want to
rent a car and the fucking,
I fucking hated this place.
Literally I started, now
I'm back all the time
because Uber, because
I can get around, right?
I can actually move,
and so that was good.
But, back to the main point.
It's stunning for me to
watch people's behavior.
Literally, fundamentally
we care about
the health of our loved
ones, money, and then time.
And I think if you really
look at what Uber's doing,
it's selling back time.
And I think if you're
thinking in start-up mode,
if you're looking for
an inspirational seed
as a starting point, I highly
recommend thinking about time.
People will massively
overpay for it.
You love time so much,
you don't even realize it.
Think about the last time
your phone or your computer
was a hundredth of a second
slower than what you're used to
on WiFi, how fucking
pissed you were.
That's how much we like time.
And so that is a big theme
that I think is gonna play out.
So again, recognizing
not everybody here
has their full idea or
everything figured out,
I think that's an
important place to play.
I think the other thing
that's really important is,
I think I play the game
a little bit backwards.
So I publicly give
away all my best ideas.
All of them.
I recognize as an individual,
I'm not gonna be able to go
and execute every great idea,
every great thought I have.
And so I've lived a life
for the last seven years
where I put out
all my content at scale,
whether through blogs,
I'm writing a lot of Medium
right now, if you
don't know what that is
you should check it out,
it's really rad.
You know, stuff like that.
And so I think early
on in one's career,
and definitely I watch a
lot of people that don't
understand what's happening now,
is the value of your
thoughts can be extreme.
So I highly recommend
thinking about putting your
thoughts out into the world
in whatever way you
communicate, whether through
audio podcasts or written form
for Medium, or video blog,
if you're thinking about
entrepreneurship,
if you're thinking about trends,
if you're thinking
about business,
you're literally just one
three-minute read
on a Medium away
from creating a huge gateway
drug to a lot of opportunity
if your thought is deemed
as smart or forward-thinking
or different by
another thought leader
or somebody who's
got an opportunity.
And I'm surprised,
I think this is very residual
from the way it used to be
in the world of
patents and ideas,
I love when, my assistant's
got a great thing now in this.
Once in every four months
somebody sends an email saying,
I've got a huge start-up
that I want you to invest in,
but you've gotta
sign this NDA, right?
Which literally every
time gets an email back
that says fuck you, right?
(Audience laughter)
And the reason is,
I'm a humongous believer
that ideas are shit, and that
execution's the game, right?
We've all got ideas,
everybody's got ideas.
Do you know how many fucking
ideas we all have here?
We could probably sit here
for the next two hours,
draw them all out,
record them, and predict
the next 78 great start-ups
over the next nine years.
And?
So I think the thing
that is another theme
in entrepreneurship is
there is way too much fodder
brought to the idea.
Uber was Magic Cab
three years earlier.
Uber is not an idea,
Uber existed.
It was called Magic Cab.
But the guys that executed
it sucked, so they lost.
So I think, you know,
if there's any level of romance
left in this room about your
idea, I'd like to suffocate it.
Because I think
the actual situation
is what you actually do with it.
And so that leads
me to the last point.
I'm, you know, maybe
it's because I was born
in a communist country, maybe
it's 'cause I came from zero,
but I really think that
people who think they're
entrepreneurs, that don't work
15 to 17 hours a day, aren't.
I really believe that.
I'm sure that's short-sighted
and one-dimensional,
but I just believe it
with my entire soul.
It blows me away of watching
the start-ups I'm investing in,
where they're leaving half
day Friday during the summer
to go to the
Hamptons to hook up.
It, you know, cool,
I get it, I wish I could do it,
but I think that there's
a pretty substantial
soft mentality in
the game right now,
and what's deemed as hard work
is probably not gonna
be deemed as hard work
by your grandparents
or great-grandparents,
and definitely
the opportunity at hand,
when you're
taking people's money.
I mean look, I think one thing
that should be talked about
as well is,
I would say 80% of the kids
that I'm giving money
to between 22 and 25,
as you can tell,
I'm not traditional
and so we get
nice relationships.
I would say 80% of them
tell me right to my face
that they actually have
no worry whatsoever
to lose my money.
That it's awesome, right?
I'm sure you're thinking it too.
Like, cool,
I'll raise a million bucks,
I'll learn a fuckload.
If I lose, I'm still just 26,
I've got plenty of time.
I'll take all that experience
and I'll go apply it.
Let me tell you one thing
about that
experience and applying it.
One of the things
that's very dangerous,
if you think you're gonna
be great, I highly recommend
that you be very smart
about how you go about this.
Because the thing that most
people don't talk about
is the fact that that check
box in the loss column
eliminates you from a lot of
opportunity the next go-around.
And so a lot of people right
now, they're taking money
and just starting shit 'cause
it's easy, and who knows?
And it's like
fucking roll it, right?
What's happening is when you
lose, all the people that are
you're gonna look for money
in the future, and the market,
and your fucking Wikipedia
that say you fucking lost,
and all that shit,
it's all there.
And so I think there's a
lack of thinking about legacy
and long-term marathon
thinking right now,
in a sprinter's mentality
where there is a lot
of access to capital and
everything feels shiny.
So I'd like to instill some
level of giving a shit about
10 or 14 or 19 years out too.
I'd like to do some
Q&amp;A if that's cool.
Yeah, man.
What's your name?
- [Shane] I'm Shane.
- Shay. Shay?
- [Shane] Shane.
- Shane.
- [Shane] Thanks for coming out.
- I liked Shay better.
(audience laughter)
- [Shane] Can we start
our company tomorrow, or
do we protect our legacy?
- That's a great question.
So I think you can start your,
so perfect, thanks,
I am a contradiction
so fuck you, Shane.
(audience laughter)
I think you do both, and
this is what I mean, right?
There's a big difference between
going to 15 tech conferences,
using all your leverage,
getting to everybody
that sat up here,
say you've got it,
getting those checks,
versus, you know, borrowing
like 30 grand from a rich friend
or your parents or, you know,
there's a way to do both.
Right? And so I would do both.
I mean, if you, look,
let's play this game.
And don't bullshit me
because I might call on you
and then expose you.
How many people
here really, really think
they've got their idea
and they're ready to go?
I really think you should leave.
With all my fucking heart.
Like, leave right the fuck,
walk out of this room
and go do it, right?
Because I really believe
that tomorrow something bad
can happen and it's really
good for you guys right now.
You could really
get 200 thousand,
you know this, right?
It's crazy,
the default that we think
of how easy it is to get money.
You know how hard it
was to get money in 1998
when I came out of the game?
You couldn't get 50 buck
from somebody, right?
It's so fucking bonkers because
Hollywood dictates thinking.
Guys, Zucks' fucking movie
fucked with people's heads.
And you're taking
advantage of that.
So I think that what happens is,
and listen,
this is me being a historian.
I wasn't in the game
from Web 1.0 bubble.
I was in New Jersey
building a wine store
during Web 1.0 bubble,
so I wasn't in those little
cosmo.com, pet.com game.
I was being practical with
my $15,000 a year marketing
and building my business.
I mean, all those guys and
gals did the same thing.
They fucking went out,
they had the moment
that you have right now, they
fucking were worth a drillion
on paper, 'cause everything
went IPO back then, right?
And then, like April happened,
and everybody lost everything
and they were all working
for like FOX, and fucking
The New York Times and Conde
Nast, the next fucking day.
(audience laughter)
And so, you know, one
more time, who's got it?
Who's got it right now?
You need to
really, really debate it.
And the only dynamic that
I would even accept is like,
you love your parents so
much and they're still
so fucking old-school that
it would hurt their feelings.
But other than that, there's
literally no other excuse.
- Questions.
Yes.
- [June] My name is
June, thank you so much
for coming.
- June?
- [June] Yes, June,
like the month.
So, what did Zuck and all
the other guys who came,
what did they do, right,
that they you knew
that they were the spotlight,
they were the winners?
- Well, the things with
Tumblr, Twitter and Facebook,
they had all already won.
Like, I love when
people are like,
"He is such a forward thinker,"
I'm like, I'll take it, but
fuck, they were already winning.
It was 2007, Facebook
was fucking huge.
Twitter, I felt like, I just
felt intuitive about Twitter.
Coming from email marketing
and being a marketer
and a salesman, I understood
how building an audience,
and then that audience,
like email marketing
was like you blasted
people, and they did shit.
But like forwarding emails
to your entire address book,
that died by like '99, right?
And so, when Twitter came,
thinking like I was gonna
push something out and
then people were like,
"I'll pass that on,"
I was like, fuck.
Word of mouth, right?
So Twitter as a
product spoke to me,
it's why I've over-indexed on
it, it's been my foundation,
that was a little bit different.
And then Ev,
who I bet on more than Jack,
it was more Ev, and my whole
theory on that was well,
he built Blogger
and sold it to Google,
he's already won once, and
that was kind of a nice thing.
It's fun to bet on
somebody who's been able
to see it through.
Tumblr was interesting.
So, I'm a straight creeper.
On the way here today at JFK,
I literally got to my gate,
looked around, found like
four 13-year-old girls,
literally sat behind them and
watched everything they did.
(audience laughs)
So by the way, real
quick, if you ever hear
that I go to jail, just
know it was market research.
(audience laughter)
And I did that today,
and what did I watch?
I watched them spend 99%
of their time on Instagram,
Yik Yak and Snapchat. Right?
And so that's what happened
with me and Tumblr in 2007.
It was a little different
then, it was laptops.
Phones are better,
you look less creepy.
I just started getting a
sense that junior high kids
were on Tumblr way more than
anybody was talking about it.
That was a good one for me,
'cause I'm New York-based,
Karp was in New York.
Karp is super artist,
I'm super businessman,
so there was a
nice yin and yang.
By that point I knew how to
respect that fucking nerd shit,
and not scare them.
So, yeah, it just worked out.
I mean, this is
how insane 2009 was.
I joined Tumblr, and
Tumblr on the dashboard,
put "GaryVee joins Tumblr"
on everybody's dashboard
for a week.
It was just a different world.
I got into a
series B at 14 million.
They already had users.
Now, like somebody farts an idea
and gets 14 million pre-product.
So it was a different market.
Birchbox is probably
the best one.
Birchbox had 60 no's,
I wrote the first check.
How many people are
familiar with Birchbox?
Cool, so Birchbox,
if you don't know
you should check it out,
it's two Harvard HBS girls,
they got like 60 noes.
I remember sitting
in that meeting
and investing on the spot,
and they were super pumped
and then they told
me they got 60 no's,
which was probably
a smart strategic move.
And I remember just leaving
that meeting thinking
that was just
straight sexism, right?
Like that was the only thing
I could wrap my head around,
that people just didn't
wanna invest in the girls.
I couldn't understand, 'cause
the model was phenomenal.
It's like, here's our
business model.
We're gonna sell people makeup
samples that we get for free.
Right?
Back to my first business,
of ripping people's flowers,
ringing their doorbells and
selling, it felt like that.
I'm like, this is a good model.
No overhead, and then
I remember telling them,
I'm like look, if we can do
customer acquisition at scale
and get enough leverage,
eventually makeup brands
are gonna pay
you to be in there.
And that's what's happened
with that company.
That one was more them,
they were so sharp.
I literally have never...
I'm acutely aware
of like, racism,
I got out of Russia
by being Jewish.
My parents were super
persecuted in the Soviet Union
and so I've always been
hypersensitive to it,
but that one was
the most extreme case,
because they crushed and
knew what they were doing.
And it's great to watch that
go out and actually become
such a big company.
But simple things, like Yik Yak.
I fucked up and
didn't see it through,
which I'm pissed about,
but the only reason
I even reached out to them,
just to give you an example,
like messing up.
Nine or 10 months ago,
I could have gotten in
at a four million
valuation, they just raised
at a $350 million valuation.
And the only reason I got
to that gateway is that
every morning when I wake
up and go take a crap,
the first thing I do on my phone
is look at the iTunes
top 150 free apps.
And Yik Yak just
started showing up.
150, 137, 123, 123.
Like what the
fuck is this, right?
And Secret and
Whisper were getting
all the
Silicon Valley attention,
yet they weren't
even showing up on that,
and just knew normal
kids were doing it.
Same thing happened
with Snapchat,
I remember creeping on
13-year-old girls
for a couple months
and being like, what the
fuck is that yellow thing?
On their phone, like
it's always showing up.
That was good, 'cause it was
yellow, it was easy to see fast
and not get beat
up by their dad.
(audience laughter)
And so I spend all of my
time looking at behavior.
At the end of the day all I do
is reverse engineer behavior,
and that's what I figured
out I was good at.
Because I was such
a great salesman,
I was able to reverse
engineer as I got more mature
and older, I'm like,
"Ah, I'm a great salesman
"'cause I actually am
really paying attention
"to what you're doing."
Like when I took over
my dad's liquor store,
I made a lot of money as a
teenager selling baseball cards,
all I used to do was stand
behind a baseball card table
and just people in malls would
walk by and look at your case
and I would just literally
watch their eyes and be like,
what are they responding to?
So UI, UX, my designer
friends are always freaked out
of how "good" I am at it,
'cause they think
I'm a business guy,
I shouldn't be good at that,
but that's all I've ever
done my whole life at scale.
I feel like I'm doing
it right now.
I'm watching
what's happening here.
So, I use my EQ to do my thing,
and that's why I'm such a big
fan of betting on strengths.
I think that's the
unknown thing about Zucks.
I mean, Zucks gets portrayed,
definitely in the movie
and just in general,
like, he's got crazy EQ.
He really understands people.
I think he's a really
smart entrepreneur.
- Yes?
What's your name?
- Simone.
- How are you?
- [Simone] Good, how are you?
- Good.
- [Simone] What was
your biggest regret
out of all of your businesses
that came out on honestly?
You don't seem really regretful.
- Yeah.
Yeah, you know regrets
are interesting for me.
Look, I have a
ton of them, right?
If you go look at my first
book, it's called Crush It!
In there I thank
my entire family
and one random human
being, Travis Kalanick,
CEO and Co-founder of Uber
and I passed on
the angel round of Uber.
I literally left
$700 million on the table
by not investing in my
buddy after I just told you,
you bet on people
and this and that.
It happens, right?
So I have plenty of
things to regret, right?
I regret the fact that I,
and look, don't cry for me,
I'm going to make
$200 million
because I got in the next round.
But, but. but
I regret that when I was doing
open cart optimization on
winelibrary.com in 1997
that I wasn't smart
enough to realize
that if I turned
that into a product
and sold it to Amazon
for $500 million dollars,
I would have make
a fuckload more money
than selling 18 more bottles
of Pinot Noir, right?
(audience laughter)
But very honestly,
you've got me pegged.
I'm basically not capable
of really regretting it.
I'm trying to answer
your question
and not be a
douche bag about it,
but regretting feels to me like
the opposite of
entrepreneurship, right?
I just think it means
looking back
and I think speed is
the number one variable
that most people in this
room will struggle with.
That is the variable
difference that I think,
that's what Travis and Zucks.
Zucks moved, so when Mark bought
Instagram for a billion dollars,
a couple months earlier
I did some Fox program
and I said that, I was
like, it was December
and they're like, "Hey, make
some predictions for 2013."
I was like, Facebook's going
to buy Instagram, right?
Cool, whatever.
Four months later it happens
and CNN asks me to come on
because the video went
a little viral in the
tech community,
so I was on Piers Morgan.
On Piers Morgan's show,
his opening line is,
"This company's 550 days old,
"how the hell is it
worth a billion dollars?"
And my opening line is,
"They stole it."
I get out of the studio,
I'm hardcore Twitter,
so I go on it and literally
there are thousands of Tweets
of people calling
me a fucking idiot.
So literally that night,
from like 10 o'clock at night
to four in the morning,
I favorited
every single one of
those tweets by hand.
(laughter)
All of them.
I think this is a good story,
because this is what an
entrepreneur, I think, does.
I favorited them all.
And then, I guess last
year this time, right?
Facebook bought
WhatsApp for $18 billion
and every article, like the
next day after the news came out
is like, oh wait a minute,
they fucking stole Instagram.
And no joke, for a week,
my wife and I went to
Turks and Caicos
for a weekend, right?
Luckily she just likes to
read and I can't bother her
and I laid on a beach for 19
hours a day, two days in a row,
and replied to every single
person that called me an idiot
and said, "What now, bitch?"
(audience laughter)
(applause)
I really think I just wanted
to get that in and humble brag,
but I don't remember
why I said that.
Oh, why I said it.
So Zuck's offered three
billion for Snapchat
and a lot of people didn't,
like that seemed insane.
But I don't think anybody thinks
that's insane anymore, right?
And so what he's
really smart is he
understands the gateway
drug is important to him.
Because the 15 year old
girl right now in America
is not going to
be a Facebook user.
And so he needs to keep
having the next one, right?
Luckily he's got the right
one right now with Instagram,
but every day that Snapchat
becomes the next one,
he needs to figure that out.
But I think he sees it and so
like, it takes that vision.
Travis knew that
he had to move to
every market
faster than Lyft, right?
And so he just kept
raising money if he could
and that was
the right execution.
So I think speed
is something that people
really need to wrap
their head around.
- Yeah man.
- What's up, man? Alex.
- Alex, what's up man?
- [Alex] What do you think about
Snapchat's new Discover page?
- I think every platform's
gonna be a media company,
and so I think it
makes a ton of sense.
I think everybody in this room
is gonna watch a feature film
that's gonna be Facebook-only,
I think there'll be a
number one hit sitcom
on Snapchat only.
All that matters is the
attention graph, right?
Where the fuck are
our eyes and ears?
Where are they, right?
And I can tell you right
now if I want to sell
to a 16-year-old
girl in America,
I want to be in Snapchat, right?
So I thought it was a huge coup
for the media companies
that were launch partners
because some of them
I think we'd all agree
are stodgy and not great,
and for them this was a
little bit of good value.
I think it was a really
smart move by Snapchat
because I really
live in this world.
A lot of the big
advertisers look at them
as too young.
You only have 13-year-olds.
So this kind of grew them up.
I think Emily White is a
really interesting executive
for a lot of
people in this room.
I think she's super
inspirational
boys and girls in this room.
Emily White,
if you don't know her,
Google, Facebook, Instagram
and now the COO of Snapchat.
I think she's a beast
and I think it was
a really smart play
because it instantly made
them more mature, right?
I've been fucking
yelling about Snapchat
for like two years.
Finally when that happened,
I got like 9,000 emails
from like old fucking
white dudes saying, "Oh."
I was like, "yeah, dick."
You know, like "Oh."
You know,
like hundreds of millions
of people's attention
fucking matters.
What pisses me off,
where you're seeing I'm
getting a little pissed,
is Facebook just
went through this.
The first time
makes sense, right?
It never happened before.
But Facebook
was only college kids.
Now it's your
fucking grandmother.
That's what happens.
And so that will continue.
The fastest growth
on Instagram right now
is 40 to 50-year-old women.
The fastest growing sector
of people taking selfies,
fastest growing.
So it's a smaller base
but it's still volume.
Fastest growth of selfies
taken on Instagram
are 40 to 45-year-old women,
like straight-up
fucking cougar selfies.
(audience laughs)
Right?
And again, back to watching.
I'm watching people have
conversations real quick off
that reaction,
and people are like,
"Yeah, my fucking ma."
People know
what's going on, right?
Your mom's on Instagram now,
24 months ago she
didn't know what it was.
That's just what it is.
That's just what's
always gonna happen,
because what's happening
is we're living through
the age-ification,
the downward
age-ification of society.
The number one
thing I love right now
is that the average
42-year-old American woman
in her behavior,
the clothes she buys,
what she does, how she
hangs out with her friends,
is acting like the
average 29-year-old woman
only 10 years ago.
Nobody wants to be old.
I'm 39.
Like I shouldn't
be dressed like,
do you know what
the 39-year-old version
of me looked like 15 years ago?
Nobody wants
to get old, it sucks.
And there's a flip side to it.
Whereas only 10 years ago,
a 15-year-old would look up
to their 18-year-old sibling
and listen to the same
music and all that.
That's why you're
seeing Snapchat
and Yik Yak and other things.
There's a fragmentation
even within generations.
They want their
own fucking thing,
and in a much
shorter period of time.
It used to be more
like seven to 10 years.
Now you're seeing
three years is okay,
but after that.
There's a lot of people in here
that their high school siblings
that are younger
than them don't want
to fuck with the things
that they fuck with.
And so it's interesting
what's going on
with the psychology of
generations and people,
the youth-ification
of our society.
- [Shane] Shane Jackson,
thanks so much.
This is awesome.
- Thanks, brother.
- [Shane] So you talked
about kind of how great
a time this is to
start a company--
- Yeah.
- And all that stuff.
You also talked about kind
of the problems with failing
especially early.
- Only failing, and that
was a great question.
I wanna make sure, like
I don't wanna stop anybody
because they don't want to fail.
I just want,
I just wanna say this.
There's a shitload of audacity
in the market right now,
like who gives a fuck?
I'm gonna lose this money
over the next three years,
but it's gonna be good for me
because I'm gonna
have experience.
I'm not gonna work a dick job.
I'm gonna do what I want,
and then I'll figure
it out after the fact.
I think failing's fine.
Look, I have a couple
people that have failed,
and I'm gonna re-invest
in their next idea.
I just wanna make sure
that you think you're ready
and you're not just doing it
because it's easy
money right now.
So if you think you're good,
like I have a huge fail
right now that I can't,
I mean I'm gonna invest
in this kid the whole way
because I've watched him fail,
but I've seen all
the great things he did.
The market and his idea
were off a little bit,
but he's a fuckin' assassin.
So I just wanna,
I wanted to clarify,
and I'm glad you did that
because I think
you made it better.
Better, Sean?
- [Shane] That being said,
and like--
- Shane, sorry.
- [Shane] You said ideas
were shaped by like--
- But way to have his
back, fuckin' united class.
- [Shane] If you were
20 years old right now,
what would you go do?
- I would do what
I did which was like
not give a fuck about school
and start prepping for my life.
(audience laughs)
But that's what I did, right?
It's not like, I'm not
telling you like what is cool
to say in a room of kids.
I'm telling you what
the fuck I did.
Like go Google Mount Ida
College, like, like, like...
(laughs) Did you do that?
Ok, I thought you did it.
So like, you know, like I,
I had no other gear, right?
So, but I truly feel I was
100% purebred entrepreneur.
I truly believe that,
and I truly believe that
it's probably a
high significant chance
that nobody in this class is,
and that's not bad.
I promise you 90%
and 85% and 80%
can be dramatically
more successful than me.
I probably could have used a
little 10 or 20% of other stuff
that would have leveled me out.
I was just fuckin'
off the chart.
Yeah, man?
- [Man] So you said
you came from zero,
graduated from
Mount Ida College.
Was there ever a point
where you felt like
you had to leverage
what you had to do
with what you wanted to do?
Spend your life making
money at an hourly job
working a start-up
on the side, or--
- My dad had
a liquor store, right?
And so that made it a
little bit different.
So I didn't, you know,
I came from zero early on,
but by the time my dad
lived the American dream,
so it'd be a false to say
that I did it all by myself.
It was a super small business.
It was a three million
dollar revenue business
with 10% gross margin.
We made $300,000
before expenses.
It wasn't a big business,
but I knew at 14 that I could,
that I was way better
than my dad, right?
And I was pumped
because I was so thankful
for what my dad did because like
we came here and had nothing,
and then we
had something, right?
So I had this
incredible family pride
to come in and
pay him back, right?
And to walk into
a family business
that's doing three million
and in 24 months
be doing 12 million?
And like I had to buy my own car
like at a garage sale,
by the way,
and then my brother, who's
11 years younger than me,
got a Lexus like...
I'm a little bitter, but like
I'm super proud of that part,
so I'm not sure, like I have
a little bit of a different,
like everybody, we all
have our different...
Look, look, I used to be super
disrespectful to rich kids,
but now that
they're all my friends,
(audience laughs)
I now realize, like fuck,
they've got it
shitty too, right?
Like, I have a bunch of
friends who are like fucking
really struggling to try to
navigate like that they weren't
that they didn't start
on third and a half base
and are trying to
do it their way,
and so everybody's
got their shit, right?
But what I can tell you, when
I think about entrepreneurship
I couldn't breathe.
Like, I couldn't breathe.
All I could ever do was think
about what I was gonna sell
and what I was, like,
there was no...
I mean, like I struggled to
even give a fuck about girls
like in my late teenage
years and early 20s
and like that's just natural
to like give a fuck, right?
And I struggled to like
get there because like...
I actually did better with
girls than I deserve to
because I literally
reverse engineered them
because if they would realize,
like they would realize
that I'd literally
rather go to the mall
and go to the dollar store
and buy something for a dollar
and go to a flea market on
Saturday and sell it for three
than like hang out with
them, so they liked me more
'cause they were like,
"What the fuck?"
Right like it became, it
actually gave me a good preview
to a solid thesis later on,
but it was like
that's how raw it was,
and so that's what I look for.
A lot of the people that
I'm excited about...
There's a start-up
that I'm an investor in
called Lawn Starter.
It's literally a SaaS play for
fuckin' landscapers, right?
But like I invested in this
second 'cause I'm like,
"Oh, this fucker's
like me, right?"
Like there was
just nothing else.
It was all Blow Pops
in junior high.
It was all like fuckin'
whatever, right?
Like whatever, yeah man.
- [Teacher] We only have
time for one more question
if we want to keep you on time.
- Seriously?
- [Teacher] Yeah.
- Fuck, OK.
- [Teacher] You're
gonna come back.
- I'll come back.
(audience laughs)
- What's your name, man?
- Johnny
- Johnny.
- [Johnny]
So as an investor,
what exactly do you look for?
Kids rolls up to you,
what catches your eye?
- I probably invest
80% of the time,
if I'm investing, I fully
am bought into the jockey.
And I believe enough
in their horse right?
Like you can show
me a hustler like me
and he's like,
"I'm going to fucking
"sell pillows,
that fucking go..."
and I'm gonna fuck you, right?
No matter how
much I love you, right?
But I'm often times very
romanced by the idea
but don't believe that
kids can execute it.
And so it's a mix.
So here's my strategy:
if I think you've got the chops,
I may still write a small check
just to get into your ecosystem.
Double check you and
try to make sure I get
on the second, third, and
fourth once you mature out
and maybe actually
have a good idea.
So a lot of times, so that's
why I bet on jockeys,
because I want to catch
them on the next thing,
on the next thing,
on the next thing.
And you know, when somebody
writes you that first check,
you know, look, some people
aren't going to stay loyal,
something could happen,
but like, I win that game.
I have good stickiness
by being a good dude
and by betting on someone.
So that's a little bit
of my strategy for me.
- [Teacher] 6:51.
- Cool, guys thanks
so much for having me.
- [Teacher] Wait, we're not--
- Oh, well, I'm leaving.
- [Teacher] You gotta head
out, but I know you've got--
- Yeah, I know you've got
the rest of the class.
- We know, but we're not
done with you either.
This is, I mean, have we
ever squeezed 45 minutes
of stuff you can use for
the rest of your life?
This has been remarkable,
really remarkable.
Now, this guy talks
a lot of places,
you've seen him online,
you've seen his--
- What are you talking about?
None of these fuckers
even knew who I was.
(laughter)
- They've got to
read your email.
But it's been a while,
we've been wanting
to get him here
for a couple years
and one of our common friends
made the connection happen,
so we don't know when
he's going to come back.
But I saw everyone writing,
I know what you picked up,
so let's give him a little bit
of something to think about.
Five years from now and
maybe five minutes from now,
what are you not going to forget
about this talk that
Gary can take with him?
You guys ready?
- [Gary] Oh,
this is cool, I like this.
- Bet on your strengths and
forget about what you suck at.
- Go all in on your strengths.
- Don't give a fuck
about your weaknesses.
- Oh, my God.
(laughter)
- Understand the gateway drug.
- Time, execution and behavior.
- Ideas are shit,
execution is the game.
- Ability to adjust.
- It's all about people's time.
- [Teacher] Speak up.
- If you want to be an anomaly,
you have to act like it.
- The value of
thoughts are extreme.
- Speed is key.
- You need to do you.
- If you're itching,
start tomorrow.
- [Audience Member]
You've got to be hungry.
Audit yourself.
- [Audience Member]
Audit who you are.
- Reverse engineer women.
(laughter)
- [Gary] I like that
Johnny Damon
type character
in the left corner.
- Who's over on
the other side, go.
- But on the jockey,
not the horse.
- Ability to adjust.
- Cougars take selfies.
(laughter)
- Last one, right here.
- People will
massively pay for time.
- [Teacher] One more,
anyone else, here we go.
- Bet on your strengths,
don't give a fuck
about your weaknesses.
- Nice guys get dick.
(laughter)
- Wow.
- [Gary] It's true,
when you take things
out of context it's like--
(applause)
Thanks guys, thank you, thanks.
(hip-hop music)